sooner or later every programmer has to
deal with time zones and I can't really
offer much advice here I can offer a
cautionary tale um I can tell you why
you really should never ever deal with
time zones if you can help it
let's imagine that someone has built an
application that lets you calculate how
many seconds something is in the past
you type in a date at a time it gives
you the number of seconds and they look
at other thing okay that kind of works
for me but let's let's add little box so
lets you change the time zone so if
you're you know if you're comparing
between now in New York and five days
ago in London you can work that out and
that's fine you know the little
drop-down lets you change which hour
forward or backward of Greenwich you are
brilliant
sooner or later after it gets a bit
popular they'll get a call from
Australia and Australia will say g'day
mate I'm not trying to accidents a home
Ostra I just shouldn't do accents
Australia will say hello um by the way
we're nine and a half hours ahead of
Greenwich and the program will go really
yeah yeah no a lot of hours so okay I
have a special case for you that's fine
a little bit later someone will call
from Nepal and they'll say hello um
we're five and a quarter hours ahead of
Greenwich and they'll say really I said
yeah yeah we've been that for ages yeah
five a quarter out great okay and then
they'll put in a special case and maybe
they'll look up the list of time zones
that the canonical list that tells you
what a thing is Allah make sure they
covered every time zone in the world and
then autumn will come along and we'll
get a call from England and in normal
say excuse me
um we're an hour out of the minute
what's going on and they'll work at hold
on the clocks just changed that's fine
no no we dealt with that we tell them we
made a note of when daylight saving
changes for us and we've put that in and
England will say no see daylight saying
change the week earlier for us it's
different depending on where you live we
we shift our clocks back a week before
you do and and at that point that's what
generally the program will start to hold
their head
there happens and realize what they've
got themselves into and that's fine you
know they'll put that in and they will
deal with each country shifting to
daylight savings time on a different day
and they'll look at the file that tells
them how to do that and they'll copy all
that it and then they'll get a call from
somewhere in the southern hemisphere
again who'll say yeah we're not shifting
back in the autumn we shift forward are
our spring is in November and that point
they'll generally start looking
longingly at their intoxicant of choice
and wondering whether they should have a
quick drink before keeping going and and
then they'll code that in as well and
then they'll get a call from some mother
out in the Pacific on the International
Dateline
Ultimo will say hello um yeah we skip
today the other year and the program
will say what so yeah we skip today we
went from December the 29th 2011 to
December the 31st we shifted from one
side of the International Dateline from
being hours and hours behind Greenwich
to being hours and hours ahead of
Greenwich helps us with trading with
Australia can you take account of that
when you work out how many days things
are and how many seconds things are in
the past that's fine there's a the file
that tells you when any country has
changed its timezone it turns out that
that happens fairly often but they're
announced ahead of schedule so as long
as you keep that file updated and code
that into programs logic as well
it'll be fine then you look back and you
notice that during World War two England
had double British summer time it went
completely on to BST and then just add
an extra hour so it was two hours ahead
of Greenwich despite having Greenwich
it's fine your deal with that it's
changed you knows I'm starting talking
as if as if it was you or me because
I've done this before it's really really
frustrating you made sure that you
subscribe to the list of when countries
are going to change their time zones
which happens apparently many times what
sometimes several times in a year
because governments change over and then
then the program lists this mythical
programmer gets a call from Libya who in
2013 with only a couple of days
Otis decided that they weren't going to
put the clocks back with enough notice
that it wasn't possible for anyone to
get the update out in time and meaning
that every Libyan computer no matter
what operating system it ran was an hour
out it's ok you you read the news
article about that you hurriedly code
that in as well and then then you get a
call from the West Bank where the
Israeli population is on a different
time zone to the Palestinian population
because one is following Israel and one
isn't and now you have two populations
of people in the same location who are
following different time zones and now
they're all having to ask themselves
whether they're on this time zone or or
this one depending on who they are and
where they are and there's no way to
code that into your program and then
then you get a call from the historian
who says right I'm trying to calculate
some some times back in the 18th century
and we changed from the Julian calendar
to the Gregorian calendar and it's not
what we lost about three weeks it's just
that we skipped right from this date to
this date and and missed the others and
can you code it so that so that it just
kind of works that out for me and it's
fine because someone else has already
told you when those dates are and you
can code that into your programs logic
as well but now it's looking really long
and really complicating this tangled
mess of spaghetti code that somehow
works down then you get a call from the
Russian historian who says yeah we only
changed the Riga Gorian calendar in the
20th century and it turns out the dates
that you skip change depend on depending
on your location and can you deal with
that as well and then you get a call
from the British historian who says that
until I think it was the 16th century
the year started on the 25th of March
just to blow your mind there and on the
24th of March 924 and then it will be
the 25th of March 925 and that is the
next day because you have gone from
December 31st 924 to January the 1st 924
because it goes
that order and it's massively
complicated and then you get the call
from the astrophysicist who says by the
way we just had a leap second and at
this point you just kind of go what leap
seconds because the earth does not
rotate to the constant speed it slows
down it speeds up as a tectonic plates
move about and magnetic fields shift or
something like that and so occasionally
the International Astronomical Union
will work out whether we need a leap
second and if you do the clocks go 23 59
58 and then it's 23 59 59 and then
instead instead of going like any
sensible time zone would it goes 23 59
60 and everything breaks because
suddenly you have 61 seconds in a minute
so depending on your implementation
either your clock gets one second out of
sync with the rest of the world or it
repeats a second the way you're meant to
deal this is something called the UNIX
timestamp a numberphile I think has
talked about this before that you have
this number that started at the first
exact second of 1970 and increments one
second per second constantly tick tick
tick and that's great because what
you're meant to do is you take whatever
whatever date has been given you and you
calculate that as a UNIX timestamp and
you put that into your database and
that'll just deal with leap seconds
exactly it doesn't of course it doesn't
because because you have universal
coordinated time which which includes
leap seconds and that it repeats
occasionally and it just includes 23:59
16 then you have astronomical time which
does not include leap seconds and has
steadily been getting out of sync with
the rest of the world because we need to
look at the Stars and design telescopes
around it and what you learn what you
learn after after dealing with time
zones is that what you do is you put
away your code you don't try and write
anything to deal with this you look at
the P
or who have been there before you you
look at the first people the people who
have dealt with this before the people
who have built the spaghetti code you go
to them and you thank them very much for
making it open-source and you give them
credit you take what they have made you
put it in your program and you never
ever look at it again because that way
lies madness Google actually has a
really really good approach to leap
seconds that they invented themselves as
an article about it on on that blog I
think that explains it and they do
something called a leap smear because
having 61 seconds in a minute or because
having a clock tick back a second can be
really really bad for massive agencies
that sort of have to synchronize
everything really precisely and have to
trust add that one bit of data was
stored before another they essentially
smear the second out
over the whole day they increase their
clock by a microsecond at a time tick
tick tick tick tick all the way through
the day so that it's sometimes maybe
even half a second out from reality but
as long as everything on their servers
is half a second out it's built to be
out of sync with the world as long as it
knows that one thing happened before
another like having continuity is more
important than actually having accurate
time